heights funeral home and cremation
services of henderson is forced to
temporarily shut down after a series of
complaints thanks for joining us at six
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
today the state funeral and cemetery
services board suspended the funeral
home's license joe mohler live in
henderson near sunset and boulder
highway with more on those complaints
joe
yeah the suspension comes after the
funeral home allegedly did not comply
with a legal agreement that was made
last winter now that legal agreement
here with heights was made after a
number of complaints surfaced several
months ago
for months hyde's funeral home has been
on probation after complaints of too
many bodies being stored for too long
poor record keeping and unsanitary
7 20 of 21 i did enter
the heights facility they were not
expecting
me to arrive there in an unannounced
visit in july from jennifer kant the
executive director with the nevada
funeral and cemetery board she
discovered more violations i did notice
three bodies that were stacked on one
gurney
two were on the bottom one was strapped
on top of the other two cans says she
noticed coolers at or near capacity and
at least one shelf was double stacked
there was an unembalmed body and a
gurney outside of refrigeration in the
hallway
near the prep room
the sheeting over the body was soiled
with blood there were some flies landing
on the body
pretty intense odor she also reported
seeing a baby's body awaiting cremation
sitting on top of another tray the
violations meant heights was not
complying with the agreement following
the first round of complaints heights
director eric lee responded to the new
allegations i'm not here to say that
they didn't those things didn't happen
[Music]
they are
isolated incidents though lee noted the
funeral home was busy during the
pandemic surges after discussion the
board voted 6-1 to suspend operations i
don't quite care
that
you mr lee don't have enough staff
where you can't hire people lee is now
required to give the state inventory of
the bodies being taken care of and 30
days to bury or cremate the bodies board
member adam garcia was disturbed by what
he heard there are loved ones
on the other end
of this whole process
who impressed you and have entrusted you
with their loved ones and you failed
them
now back out here live during the
hearing lee also did mention potentially
selling the business
we also did get in contact with
representatives there in heights we went
inside earlier today and the
representative there told us they
declined to comment reporting live in
henderson joe moore 8 news now